foreign
that I looked at and it's coming from a
new study from the Federal Reserve Bank
of Boston
men are dropping out of the labor force
because they're upset about their social
status
I'm just going to let that sit for a
second
I don't know that I've read a more
pathetic headline in my lifetime I'm
going to say it again I want you to hear
what it really is saying the headline is
men are dropping out of Labor Force
because they're upset about their social
status
what it should say is men are quitting
because it's not going the way they want
it to
oh man
I'm not making as much money as the
other guy so I'm gonna go home and live
off of mom and dad
yes snowflake you wimp
what is happening here all right now
before I go further than the data I got
to take 30 seconds on this and some of
you are going to say oh you're old
school or you're a boomer well number
one
yes I am old school number two I'm not a
boomer I'm proud member of Generation X
whatever the crap that means I've never
understood what that means but let me
tell you something you know where this
starts it's generation a total
generation where we try to make
everybody feel good and we gave
everybody a trophy or a participation
ribbon for showing up
and I got news for you people this is
what happens when we try to make
everybody feel good and we try to avoid
having them feel the sting of loss I got
news for you
there's first place
and then there's loser
I'm just being honest first or last well
but listen you're saying well kill what
about the Olympics I got they got the
the the gold medal the silver medal the
bronze oh these are Olympians who work
really hard we should acknowledge first
second third place but in Youth Soccer
when the score is five to nothing I got
news for you little buddy you lost
you lost five to nothing and by the way
the five-year-olds know these kids are
smart enough to realize that the ball
went in the other team they win in our
net twice and we haven't even sniffed
the other side of the field and you want
to know what Ken they can handle it they
can Jade they can handle it and these
kids are resilient but these dudes can't
and that's a shame now listen folks
here's the data
um
the study found that the decline in
earnings for non-college educated men
over the last four decades has increased
their likelihood of leaving the labor
force by nearly half a percentage point
now
this this might hurt some of your
feelings but I I can say this
younger white men in particular were
more likely to leave when their expected
wages fell relative to their more
educated peers but
while the white men are whistling out
turns out the ladies aren't Jade tell us
women have not seen the same level of
decline in their wages based on
education
wow that group has seen a 32 increase in
weekly earnings now there's two things I
want to get at first we have a culture
that has created this context what do I
mean very simple
we have for decades said that the
college diploma is the most desirable
way to live a life in other words if I
have a college degree I'm going to be
more successful and so the numbers have
borne out that way because companies
play the game too right oh you don't
have a degree but the bigger problem is
we have men that are leaving the
workforce all together they are taking
their ball and going home you didn't
pick me so I'm gonna go home and Mommy's
gonna make me feel better and cut me a
PB and J sandwich and let me play on the
video games all day long I'm telling you
what's happening oh I'm just I'm just
keeping her not my son's kin not my son
no better than that and and not my
brothers because of my boys you know
what and here's what needs to happen
here's the fix there's not a policy in
the world that's going to fix this yeah
it's a social problem and I'm trying to
have a little bit of fun with it but I'm
making a key point if you are a family
member if you are a mom or dad a
grandparent a brother a sister a cousin
a good friend and you are harboring and
I'm using that word on purpose yeah you
are harboring a wussified dude who's got
his feelings hurt and refuses to go work
and be a productive member of society it
is incumbent upon you to kick their butt
out okay
I'm just telling you it's a problem Ken
give me some dap I don't even know what
that means but I'll do it what's the
debt is the the DAP is I'm with you I'm
with you heart and spirit see folks I'm
getting cooler by the minute all right
now now I'm gonna go home and do that
with my 17 year old kid he's Gonna Roll
his eyes so hard they fall out of his
head you know what do you think about
what I just said and I'm not looking for
approval no this is a societal problem
it reminds me of okay I mentioned
earlier Sam and I have a talent agency
and we we book Talent all around the
world yeah and to get the job there is a
series of protocols you have to follow
and I find Ken because America is the
greatest country it was without saying
but it's cushy up in here a very good
it's cushy in comparison to some other
countries and what we find is that if
we're uh hunting talent in let's say the
Philippines or or India where life in
some areas is not as cushy when we tell
them this is what you have to do to get
the job they do that thing Lickety split
you don't ask questions jump in Jack
Flash they get that thing done whereas
some of the counterparts who are here in
the states they could be a better player
they could be better at the job but they
don't feel that they should have to do
yep and so they they and they sleep on
it and I'm like now wait a minute now
what's going on the job is the job but I
think what happens is you get cushy you
start having entitlement you start
having this I deserve mentality and I
think that I deserve mentality can be it
can it can be the beginning of the end
well it is and you've nailed it so you
all kind of for those of you that roll
drives and laughed at my whole thing
about a trophy but see this keeps
getting
um it keeps getting supported throughout
where I show up and I'm rewarded for
showing up just for showing opposed to
getting rewarded for accomplishing right
here's what happens these men are
falling out of the workforce because
they look at the competition and they're
getting beat and instead of rising up
and going all right I'll get you next
round you know what they do they go I'm
just leaving all together you know why
yeah because they've been protected from
failure that's right and failure
best I can tell Jade with every
successful woman or man in the history
of the universe failure is what
propelled them forward you can't learn
to ride a bike without wrecking a bike
it's necessity
and I'm telling you we have protected
our kids from failure and as a result
they've got no grit so what happens is
we coddle them until they get to the
real world they fail that's right they
feel like a failure because he's making
more money than I am right and so they
don't know what to do because they've
got no grit they don't know how to act
if you find anybody who's successful and
I'm not talking about you know at the
very time I'm not talking about the
Michael Jordan's I'm talking about king
Coleman if I talk to you a successful
man good at marriage good at their job
you you will list out you could probably
make a whole computer list of all the
ways that you didn't get the trophy all
the things that you endeavored at and
failed at hey I got told by a program
director in Atlanta second year into the
chase folks guy looked at me and said I
don't know why you're trying to get on
the Sports Talk station
this is a number eight market and he
said this I'll never forget he said Ken
you don't have the talent to make it in
a number eight Market oh yeah oh yeah
I've been there let me tell you
something I did and I do and here I am
Come On Son but listen it hurt
I know it didn't I'm having a little bit
of fun but I'm not puffed up I'm telling
you I went home and it rocked my world
to hear that oh yeah but somewhere in
the next 48 to 72 hours I had to decide
come on it's about what you've got to do
nobody's gonna hand you anything
snowflake like you got to get out and
take it it's like that old trick when
it's like you get ready to open the door
and then they drive forward again
yeah that's it you know you know I talk
about this all the time to my boys and
they they're sick of me saying it but
you know I'm trying to teach my kids
you're in a competition
and if you don't think you're in a
competition I got bad news for you
you're getting your head beat in you
don't even know it you're competing
against the U of yesterday and you're
competing against someone else not in an
ugly way I'm not telling you
healthy competition you're trying to
book artists come on and there's always
someone there's always someone who's
practicing more than you that's studying
more than you there you better believe
it while you're complaining they're out
there getting better yeah